this was the first time you ever really
did stand-up right I never did a
stand-up special and I never like
crafted an hour stand-up special was it
hard because you were famous and then
you decide to go do stand-up at first
everyone always kind of sucks at
stand-up so I started off doing stand-up
when I was like 23 and I didn't know
what to do like there wasn't all that
hey do a podcast
oh it was nothing to do before you met
Jimmy and you started doing the man
showing all that you were doing stand-up
right so I thought you were some kind of
like plumber or something or electrician
or a boxing coach or I was I didn't make
any money doing stand-up I tried doing
stand-up I did like open mics I didn't
really have my voice I wasn't very good
I didn't know what I was doing you know
yeah so then I just started taking
improv classes oh and then I ended up
then I was a carpenter then I was a
boxing coach then I met Jimmy I always
perceived that Jimmy was your partner in
all this you were like you know Allen
and Rossi or something and then Jimmy
went off and did the late-night thing by
himself and so I was like oh where does
that leave Adam yeah well it leaves me
in DeKalb Illinois a place that has a
jack-in-the-box
on the roof 181 people is it hard to get
that muscle working again going cuz
going up on a stage is really difficult
you know I'd had a lot of reps played a
lot of colleges when dr. Drew and I were
on MTV and had a lot of success there
and blah blah blah so it's like I had my
feet under me I knew how to be in front
of a large crowd I just need to start
putting an act together right and I
started putting an act together and it
next scene I was playing theatres and
traveling the country and it was pretty
good and then at a certain point I was
like I think I should do a stand-up
special right and here we are today and
here we are